what is up guys my name is a Shannon
welcome to episode 5 of 3d game
programming in Java
last time we successfully drew pixels on
the screen awesome isn't it and this
time this in this tutorial we're
actually going to just play around with
them and I want to show you guys how to
animate them and explain a bit more how
this code works first of all let you out
and I'm just moving it like that so that
we can see both of it let me just move
this stuff out of the way tell us let's
go to outline now I want this down here
what are you doing there we go there we
go Hospital ok so first of all let's
talk about the offsets um what's
actually happening and the great thing
about Java is it you can actually you
can actually like live code pretty much
um so you can see that as I increase
this number so to say like 250 or
something oh it moved and it did
actually move don't worry about that
it appears that is yeah it we haven't
actually dealt with sort of updating it
properly will actually probably add that
code today but yeah so basically what
it's doing is the value for X offset and
where it needs anymore the value for X
offset and Y offset is defined by these
two parameters X offset and Y offset so
by the by the second and third
parameters when we call this method and
the reason it is the second and third of
course is because in here we've put it
as the second see the comma second and
third parameters and also the reason
that we again just say draw this is
because the method the method is called
draw and we don't actually have to
initialize the object since screen
extends this class called render so yeah
that's sort of that's sort of how it
works
and of course it's going to draw it at y
plus whatever about plus what whatever
value we put here so yeah I hope you
understand how that works so yeah
a trick to putting it in the middle is
simply taking the width of because it's
X subtracting the amount of pixels we've
drawn and dividing it by two and that'll
actually pop it right into the middle I
just can see that's in the middle of the
width and you know obviously doing the
same thing for height height minus 256
divided by two well and there we go
it's right there in the middle awesome
yeah so let's talk a bit about animating
now let me just pop this back here some
flip down explaining
okay so we'll actually create a new
integer for this we'll call it an M
shorter an animate or whatever animating
being animated and we'll simply go math
sign system dot current time on seconds
and we'll take the remainder of that we
use a percentage sign for that
percentage then divide by 1000 these are
just numbers you can change them
honestly you can change these numbers
obviously animal times by matter pi
times 2 times 100 okay oh what's the
problem with this oh yeah of course
system current time milliseconds
obviously has decimal points and so we
need to convert it into an integer by
putting into in brackets in front of it
that's called cost and let's add that to
here yay there we go wonderful animation
isn't that epic it's awesome isn't it
and we can actually similarly you know
you can play around with these values
yeah man learn what they do pretty much
creasing the speed slow
even slower and you might be thinking Oh
0.5 what 0.5 doesn't make it a and it's
not an integer and it is because
basically by placing int we're saying
whatever comes after this we're
converting into an integer so it's
rounding off to the nearest whole number
actually I don't know I don't know
exactly how it works might be rounding
up might be rounding down might be just
rounding off I'm not sure so don't ask
me simple Google search will probably
help you there I just know that it
changes it into an integer that's all
you need to know okay
that's nice so yeah um you can also see
that it's leaving a trail behind itself
we can actually solve that but before we
solve that I actually want to show you
another thing and if we copy this and
paste into here we'll rename this you
know Adam to and we'll simply just
change this to cosine cause and we'll
draw it to the Y value as well then you
will see that it's not going to work
because the bracket is in the wrong
place yeah okay exception oh and a rainy
Dex out of bounds excites right okay we
need to put a boundary for this array
thing that we drew yeah okay so what it
means is that when it's basically coming
to here it's I wish let's run it again
okay something wrong okay let's just run
it from here that was beautiful okay so
it's saying that there's an array index
out of bounds we've limited the number
of arrays that we can create like the
you know the pixels to width times
height which is 480,000 and it's trying
to you know obviously draw more 480,000
173 because we're sort of getting off
the screen now it's actually really easy
to fix that and the way I'm going to fix
it is we're going to go into make an F
segment saying if wipe X is less than
zero so in other words if if this
becomes if the Y value becomes less than
zero or double vertical
sort of slashes it's right above my
enter key right below my backspace key
if you hit shift that's where the
backslash key is but you hit shift and
you press it that means or similar
similar how this means and you know that
means or so if this is true or this is
true is greater than or equal to now
I'll hide rounded up hide then continue
it's a pretty much skip and you know
we'll have to do the same thing for here
as well so if Y is this indented all
right yeah that's correct
if armed if X picks is less than 0 or X
picks is greater than or equal to R
ended up with then continue okay um
awesome
that should work let's check it out okay
that worked kind of that's odd
hmm there's some live debugging for you
guys I honestly don't know what's going
on
what is ham this is what's confining it
hi shouldn't that be now I want mmm this
is interesting
okay let's try setting this to the
height of the frame which is 600 okay
let me just stop this more exceptions
I'll hang on I change the normal value
this we want to set this to 600 oh yeah
odd it's weird hell it's not um hmm
there we go I guess we fixed that arrow
that's uh huh I don't know okay well
it's a temporary fix I might get back to
that later um I just don't want to get
distracted there um okay so yeah we got
that um I mean you know we can change
the direction by changing this to
subtract whatever you want so yeah
that's really cool we've got a nice
little thing going on here yeah and
again the great thing about Java is that
you can change these values you know in
real time and basically it'll update
straightaway so yeah check that out how
cool is that
oh yeah um yeah so play around with this
it's a lot of fun again there's no
reason why it's limiting there it's yeah
there's completely no reason why it's
being limited that's actually the height
let's check out with
yeah as you can see you know it's it's
fun we can even put this to something
like 600 and it'll yeah so there's no
problems with that which is good it's
rendering properly yeah so we have the
other problem this stuff does not go
away and it's quite easy to fix and yeah
we'll fix it now okay so the way we fix
that is quite simple in render we're
going to make a for loop which is going
to say you know if basically if or when
I becomes until I becomes greater than
width times height and simply set pixels
I equal to 0 yeah that worked ok so that
should be self-explanatory basically
it's going to remove like it's not gonna
yeah well you you can see what it did
it's going to set pixels to 0 every
frame so yeah so it's only going to draw
the most updated state this is really
cool as well if we sort of draw like a
nice trail and you can sort of start to
see the 3d possibilities if we do this
if we draw this multiple times basically
so you can see basically our plan here
is to draw multiple times but one like
back so that's hard to explain let me
just show you guys ok so when I is less
than say 100 will have 100 being
rendered i plus plus and will encase all
of this and inside the loop yeah look at
that that's cool but what I've done yet
because we actually want to add a 2 here
but yeah you can see we're getting sort
of a tail plus I whoa and let's go back
here
here and we'll add the other bracket so
it doesn't crash yeah
look at that that's marvelous okay so
now we've got this that's really cool
and you know you can adjust how many
drawers so being you know just - for
example - you know whatever number you
want ten you can sort of start to see it
at ten let's actually slow down the
movement of this just going way too fast
I don't actually know what part slows it
down hmm
no I didn't help oh yeah okay let's just
okay so that slowed it down
[Music]
okay so I'll but if we slow it down then
we're not going to be able to see enough
okay you can sort of see how it's how it
once it renders it sort of doesn't
remove it immediately like it would
because it's sort of it's rendering
multiple times basically so um yeah it's
kind of hard to show you guys since it's
going to it senses get it since it gets
removed but um yeah okay it's actually
cool um you can see if we start to
increase it though we're beginning to
get lag even on my fast computer 1000
you know its belly
it's barely coping and the reason is
that even if even if we're drawing say
200 so it's not lagging in 200 if I just
bring up the calculator real fast real
quick real fast then we can calculate
okay so how many pixels is drawing its
drawing 256 x 256
yeah so that's 65,000 times 200 so it's
drawing what is that thirteen thirteen
point one million pixels right now to
the screen so that's a lot of pixels and
it's still not lagging so it's pretty
efficient it's um it'll do for now and
basically yeah that's all I want to say
it
next we'll probably add some Alfa
support you know a bit masking all that
stuff so we can actually have
transparency later on and we will move
on and we'll see what's next so thanks
for watching guys be sure to rate the
video and if you don't understand
anything leave a comment tweet at me
that's obviously that's honestly the
best place Twitter if you need help
follow me follow me on Twitter the link
is in the description and yeah I hope
you enjoyed this and subscribe so you
don't miss a video because I'm releasing
one every day so yeah I'll see you guys
later bye
[Music]
[Music]